[Music]
mods have been supported by XCOM 2 since
its launch last year and now one of the
strategy games most popular creators is
making a sequel to a beloved mod for
enemy Unknown I'm Matt and this gamespot
news update is coming to you live from
the mothership previously known as long
war studios but bonus interactive has
announced the sequel to enemy unknowns
long war mod no details have been
revealed at this time but we do know
that the original revamp the entire game
from the campaign and voice acting to
the classes and weapons in addition to
the new mod voters plans to focus on
developing its own original games the
first of these titles is an alien
invasion strategy game called Terra
invicta players will be tasked with
assembling a council of scientists
politicians and military leaders and
taking the fight to the invaders in
outer space there's not much known about
Pavone is's projects but we'll keep you
updated as more as announced for more
news on alien invasions and the world of
video games stay tuned to gamespot